did you ever imagine that bodybuilding
would lead to acting i mean did you
really have that game plan in mind you
know my dream
was a for me to make this a ticket in
the movies
um and number two
uh to lift and elevate the whole
bodybuilding sport
and both of them have been very
successful and when movies like conan
the barbarian came out and then the
terminator
and so on my career took off and all of
a sudden your career
that was not supposed to ever become a
leading man or was then it became a
leading it is the most brilliant movie
career when you think about it because i
remember when arnold schwarzenegger
everyone said especially after hercules
comes to new york this guy is never
going to make it you were arnold strong
they dubbed your voice that was you know
that's legendary and when you look at
the list of movies that you've done it
is
unbelievable the amount of box office
gross and how great these movies are and
still are franchises thank you you know
really is amazing and you talk about
conan so when they cast you in conan the
barbarian i feel that was the
breakthrough for you were you shocked
when they offered you that part i was
not shocked i remember i was shocked
when they uh asked me to do hercules in
new york right because at that point i
had no plan yet to be in acting i was
working my way up in bodybuilding and i
said to myself i have to go to acting
class i have to really work on my accent
i have to really learn the language and
all this i was not ready at all when you
came to america you didn't know english
no no i mean i i knew a little school
english you know whatever you learned in
school but i could not really understand
the news i couldn't read the newspaper i
had to i had people talk to me very
slowly and in very simple term so i
could understand so it was really it
wasn't my beginning stage and then all
of a sudden someone called the gym and
uh he said you know we want to talk to
schwarzenegger but hercules in new york
and then joe wieder called me uh joe is
your mentor mentor and brought me to the
united states he said the arnold is
they're casting hercules and i just told
him that they should have to hire you
you're the big new bodybuilding champion
you're 22 years old they should get you
this is the best thing and
then i went to an interview with him and
they got me that they gave me the party
i didn't even have to read but i never
even talked
about shut up and don't talk he says i
do the talking you just sit there and
keep your chest out and look proud and
look strong and so he was telling them
that i'm a german shakespearean actor
and there is no such a thing i mean what
the hell is he talking about were you
insulted when the movie came out and
they dubbed your voice in or you didn't
no no i would look i was like so
uh because you said were you amazed
about being hired as conan in this case
i was so amazed
that i got just off the boat
and uh and all of a sudden if you read
about hollywood and about america
became true and this is incredible i i i
must be dreaming this is wild so i
didn't care what they did and if they
only left me in the movie for three
minutes i was in heaven to just be part
of it you're so right think about that
how crazy that is you got off the boat
and now you're in the movies one of
these unbelievable only
which was 15 years later 77 yeah 15
years later but it was actually in 1977
after pumping out iron came out uh ed
pressman
who is a famous producer um he came to
me and he says you i'm going to riot i'm
going to buy the conan rights and so so
they they hired me to do a whole series
of conan movies and so of course this
was like the first time where i was now
with the studio with universal studio
with one of the biggest producers tina
delaurentis one of the classes producers
at presmas
i was i was in were you nervous when you
went on the set of conan the barbarian
you only seem like such a confident guy
but i would think back then i was
wondering did he take acting lessons oh
yeah i mean by that time i have taken so
many acting lessons and voice lessons
and speech lessons and accent removal
lessons you really worked out that guy
should give me this my money back
waiting for that accent to disappear
it isn't necessarily that you were
gifted physically it was the hard work
you absolutely the work itself and the
belief
in yourself
is the most important thing because from
the time you set the big goal you will
have the naysayers say this is stupid
you would never make it this is
ridiculous come on i mean no one has
ever done this but they totally forget
that you can break new grounds and you
can do things that no one else has ever
done before and i was determined to do
that